president biden has promised there will
be consequences as an investigation is
launched into the border patrol agents
seen on horseback allegedly mistreating
migrants at the u.s mexico border the
huge encampment by a bridge in del rio
texas with nearly 15 000 migrants less
than two weeks ago is now gone but
officials are keeping close watch on
shallow parts of the rio grande river
for a possible new wave of people trying
to enter the u.s manuel bajorquez has
more
this is the migrant encampment in del
rio just days ago this is what it looks
like now as of right now there were zero
persons under the bridge
of the almost 15 thousand migrants
mostly from haiti at least 2 000 have
been deported 5 000 are still being
processed and could be expelled the rest
officials say were either released into
the u.s under the asylum process or
returned to mexico voluntarily
department of homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas rejected
calls to stop the deportations we have
in fact determined despite the tragic
and devastating earthquake that haiti is
in fact capable of receiving individuals
this is why your country the controversy
over border agents on horseback
disbursing migrants continued with
president biden weighing in of course i
take responsibility i'm president but i
was horrible what to see as you saw to
see people treat it like they did horses
barely running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay i see the humanity
i see the hope
i see their lives
gerleen joseph is co-founder and
executive director of the haitian bridge
alliance and has been working with
haitians at the border do you see a
difference between the biden approach
and the trump report approach
unfortunately we are seeing the batting
administration continuing the same
policy the same approach cruel
inhumane
we want different
feeders and genvare crossed through 11
countries he fears being sent back to
haiti
there's no life for them he says i want
to cry when i see people in the news
deported there's no life for them there
how am i going to live there there's no
life there
the mayor of del rio is urging federal
officials to do a better job of
listening to local officials here along
the border who he says warned of a
looming crisis he added that 10 babies
were born during the time the migrants
were here
for cbs saturday morning manuel
bajorquez del rio texas